Cricket,
a quiet sport.
Pioneered by the British.
Measured, considered, timeless.
Just a couple of decades ago,
cricket was struggling
to attract audiences
and its commercial future
was very much in doubt.
Now, it has the second
biggest sporting franchise
in the world, bettered only by the NFL.
At the center of its
success is one country
and its record breaking tournament,
the Indian Premier League.
So there's been a revolution in cricket.
Traditionally what used to happen,
when English cricket started,
cricket in the rest of the world stopped.
Now, such is the glamor of IPL,
such are the riches the IPL provides
that English cricket has
to bow down to India.
There are 74 games now in the IPL
and each one is valued at over
10 million pounds for one game.
There's no way that other
formats of the game before
could have commanded that sort of
financial power or value.
The figures that are talked about is that
80% of world cricket's income
is provided by India in
one form or the other.
India currently has a population
of 1.4 billion people.
IPL has a viewership of
almost 700 million people.
Worldwide fanbase for cricket
is about two and a half billion people.
We are 27% of that total
fan base worldwide.
So potential to grow this
viewership? Immense, massive.
This is the story of how
one country became the driving force
behind the biggest sporting
turnaround of the 21st century.
Well, cricket is this unique English game.
The English invented most of the sports,
but cricket is probably unique in that
the two sets of players
are doing opposite things.
One of them is playing with a bat
and the other one is playing with a ball.
It's one of those kind
of quiet enigmatic sports
to describe, I think.
It's the battle between runs,
the number of runs you can score
versus the number of wickets.
And a wicket is when a batter gets out
and so it's a contest
between runs and wickets.
The overall aim of the game
is to score more runs
than the opposing team.
A run is essentially a point
and it's given every time
a batter runs between the wickets,
which is possible after
the ball has been bowled.
Four runs are given if
the batsman hits the ball
beyond the boundary of the pitch,
with the ball having hit the ground.
A six is given for batters
who can clear the boundary
without the ball hitting the ground.
The fielding team bowls
to the batting team.
A fielder bowls in sets of six balls,
which are called an over.
After each over, the bowler changes.
The best way to prevent the
batting team from scoring
is by getting the batsman
out or taking wickets.
This can be done in many ways:
bowling, catching, or running out.
Once 10 of the 11 batsmen are out,
their innings finishes and
they can't score anymore runs.
The same is true if they run out of time,
which varies depending on
the type of cricket game
and is where the most revolution
has taken place in recent years.
Its most traditional format
is multi-day cricket,
so where it's played with a red ball
and there are
three results possible:
win, lose, or draw.
So I know people are completely stumped
by the fact that you can play a game
for five days and still
draw at the end of it.
Cricket's complicated
rules and long playtime
meant it struggled to appeal to fans
outside Commonwealth countries
who had deeply historical
ties to the game.
Invented in England in the 1600s,
cricket arrived in
other parts of the globe
during the late 17th and 18th centuries
via British colonizers.
The British took the game to
different parts of the world,
as they expanded, as they
went in search of trade,
and then they acquired territories.
They didn't tell people
you have to play our sport.
They played their sport
and the other people,
seeing the British play the
sport, was attracted by it.
While a number of the
Commonwealth countries
adopted the game as their own,
one managed to turn the
sport into big business.
I think the Indians, who have
been given no chance at all,
are likely to give a
great deal more trouble
than many people expect.
When I was a very young boy,
that was a long time ago,
in the fifties, as a five year old,
I was taken in India, in Mumbai,
to watch England play India.
Mihir Bose, the BBC's
first sports news editor,
is one of cricket's
best known commentators.
His most recent book, "Nine
Waves: The Extraordinary Story
of How India Took Over the Cricket World"
traces the country's rise
from colonial dependency
to global dominance within the sport.
The money in cricket came
through, and this was worldwide,
came through people at
the gates buying tickets.
When a team came over
in England, Australia,
West Indies, New Zealand, or whoever,
there would be in the cities,
what was called test fever.
People would want to buy tickets,
there would be long queues
to get tickets and so on
and that was the situation
'til well into the 1990s.
Television had shown
its potential in India
during the 1982 Asian Games,
but it wasn't until the 1990s
when domestic viewership
reached critical mass
that its full potential
could be capitalized on.
The cricket authorities in India realized
television stations were
prepared to pay big money.
By then, crowds had
declined all over the world.
People were watching on television
and English cricket and
Australian cricket found
that when they played India,
they could sell their
television rights to these
Indian television stations
for a lot of money.
And that is where India, if you like,
took over the world game.
While the sports original days long format
continued to have an appeal
with longstanding fans,
cricket struggled to entice
new, younger audiences.
This pressure only intensified
as the unparalleled
popularity of mega franchises like the NFL
and the EPL continued to proliferate.
In an attempt to reinvigorate the sport,
a variety of shorter formats
with fewer overs were created.
England, finding audiences
were not coming to cricket,
spectators were not coming to cricket,
devised a new format of the game
where only 20 overs were
bowled by each side.
You know, shorten the game
because then you could play
the game in an English summer,
start at one or two o'clock,
play 'til about seven
o'clock, eight o'clock,
and somebody could
finish their work at five
and just pop in for two or three hours.
That was the idea.
England's 20 over format,
also known as T20 or 20-20,
launched its first professional
tournaments in 2003.
The shorter format made it
a much better fit for broadcasters.
Sky Sports televised eight group matches
and the entirety of finals day live.
England's T20 World Cup
was a success domestically
and had proved the potential
of a more explosive version of the game.
But it would take a
total disruption in 2008
to change the course of cricket.
And that disruptor came in the form
of the Indian Premier League.
No matter which times on your end,
over the next 51 days, it's only one time.
And that is to celebrate
cricket's biggest festival.
Welcome to the Vivo Indian Premier League.
They made it into a spectacle
and the old-fashioned
traditionalists find this abhorrent.
To them, that's not cricket.
Cricket is theater where, you know,
you have intellectual discussions
as to where the ball is
played and so on and so forth.
Here they said, no, no,
you don't need all that.
You want entertainment.
You want to rival what
the cinema offers you,
what any other form of
entertainment offers you.
The IPL didn't just take inspiration
from America's pre-show
entertainment and pyrotechnics.
It also adopted a similar league structure
where the same teams compete every year.
For the IPL, they devised
completely new teams.
So it became Mumbai
Indians owned by one of the
richest businessmen in India,
composed some of them from Mumbai,
composed of players from around the world,
or the Chennai Super Kings, or you know,
the Kolkata Knight Riders.
So they came up with these exotic names.
You know, the one difference is
this is not about a country
playing another country.
The one difference is you're
able to, as a franchise,
attract the best in an auction,
which is done prior to
the season beginning,
where you bid for the
best players in the world
for a certain price tag.
How much has the IPL, you know,
changed the face of cricket
because of the money involved?
Yeah, well, I mean the money involved
is huge for the players these days.
This is a time of upheaval in sport,
where new moneyed leagues
promising big payouts
threaten to upend the status quo.
From Saudi Arabia's
controversial LIV golf tour
that saw golfers sign up despite concerns
over the country's human rights record
and then lose their place
from renowned PGA tours,
to the proposed European Super League,
a breakaway competition in football
designed to guarantee millions
of dollars for a select few
at the expense of long
established leagues.
And the IPL is no different,
with only 10 teams competing,
each under owners with deep pockets.
It quickly attracted the
world's best players,
causing issues for any other tournaments
that took place during the IPL season.
Player choice, scheduling,
the kind of proliferation of
short format leagues whilst
also trying to schedule
international cricket, whether
it's test match cricket,
the domestic game, the
other international formats.
You know, it is quite a
challenging jigsaw puzzle.
The organization unofficially
in charge of putting that puzzle together
is the Board of Control for
Cricket in India, or the BCCI.
While the International
Cricket Council is named
the global watchman, money,
as is often the case, wields power.
The humble truth here is the BCCI
is the richest body today
in the world of cricket
across the globe.
And I think it's purely
because of the success of IPL,
massively, so you've got
sponsorship deals coming,
pouring through every
single corner of the room
into the BCCI.
80% of world cricket's
income is provided by India
in one form or the other.
There's television rights,
there are commercial deals
when India play abroad,
if you look around the
stadiums, the marketing
of the sponsors names
are Indian sponsors names
because they have got the rights.
They want their names on television
because Indians are watching
and therefore they'll sell the product.
So the BCCI obviously
continues to, you know,
aggregate power in a sense purely because
of the type of consumers
it has at its disposal.
The Indian consumer, like I said,
700 million people watching IPL,
which has probably the
least number of games
across any sporting, you
know, format across the world.
I'm not just talking
cricket, I'm talking NFL,
I'm talking about MLB, I'm talking EPL.
This has the least number of games.
It has the maximum viewership.
The success of the
2022 IPL media rights e-auction
highlighted just how successful
this franchise has become
in such a short period of time.
The TV and digital rights
for 2022 - 2027 matches
collectively sold for $6.2 billion.
This not only reaffirmed the IPL
as the leading cricket league,
but also made it the second
most valuable league globally.
At more than $13 million per match,
the IPL has surpassed global leagues
such as the EPL and the MLB
and is second only to the NFL.
Disney bagged the TV rights
and a joint venture between Paramount
and Mukesh Ambani's Reliance Industries,
won digital streaming rights.
Media companies are constantly
working hard to make sure
they get the right form of content
such that the consumer loyalty
continues to stick and grow.
If you look at the case of Netflix
in the two quarters that went by
they actually said they're
gonna come off massively
on their consumer numbers
only because, you know,
they're not able to penetrate
countries like India,
which require a different form of content.
I'm not saying that they
should go after cricket
as a possible broadcasting thing.
They may, who knows, but
if you get, you know,
sport which is universal, has no language,
something like a football or a cricket,
which actually attracts more consumers
given its religious following
in those specific countries,
I don't see a reason why you
will see more media companies
coming and you know,
trying to get a partnership
with the BCCI, given the
massive fan following
across the world.
It's widely agreed upon that media
is what's propelled the values of teams
to such astronomical heights.
In the US, the Big 10, a
college football conference,
just signed an $8
billion media rights deal
and Apple signed onto a 10
year global broadcast deal
to stream major league
soccer worth $250 million.
With so much untapped revenue to play for,
a flurry of new T20
leagues are being created
in an attempt to ride the
wave of the IPL's success.
South Africa have started fleshing out
details of the new T20 league.
Players are already on board.
A broadcast deal has been confirmed
and team owners revealed.
SA's previous attempts that
getting an international
T20 league off the ground have failed.
South Africa and the UAE
are both set to launch
new T20 leagues in 2023,
adding to an already
packed cricketing calendar.
These tournaments will
put a further strain
on resources and talent,
especially as the current
ruling by the BCCI states
no Indian national player can
take part in other leagues
unless they permanently retire
from the IPL and national cricket.
The thinking here is
that players competing
in other T20 tournaments will
take fans to those franchises
which could lead to tougher competition
in terms of attraction, attention,
and brand value for the IPL.
So you see in T20 leagues, in Australia,
the Big Bash League, the
Caribbean Premier League,
one in England, and now two
new leagues being launched,
just announced, one in South Africa
and the other one in Dubai,
the Emirates Cricket Board.
Now the fact is, in all of these leagues,
Indian players who have
a global fan following
are not allowed to play, that's the rule.
And if you can't get, you know,
the likes of MS Dhoni or Virat Kohli
or some of the other big boys that we have
playing cricket across the
world for their country
and in the IPL League,
I think you'll lose that many audiences.
In an interview with ANI
Sports in August 2022,
the BCCI Vice President Rajiv Shukla
commented on the matter:
"Our Indian Premier League
is itself a huge league
and we cannot allow any of our players
to attach themselves to any
foreign league in any manner."
The owners of the IPL teams
have found a clever way
to compete with these burgeoning leagues:
Buying the competition.
All teams within South
Africa's new T20 tournament
have been bought by the
owners of IPL teams.
There are 10 team owners in India.
All of them have tasted
immense success in IPL.
They've seen their evaluation
go from literally nothing to now
close to $2 billion per franchise
given the media rights valuation.
When you taste that kind of success
in a limited timeframe of 10 or 15 years,
you certainly want to experiment
as an owner, a team owner,
and see what this can do
if other leagues take off.
Now, non-cricketing countries,
seeing the opportunity that T20 brings,
are beginning to hedge their bets.
Not only is the shorter
format an easier game
to sell to those countries
with less understanding of the sport,
but the money floating around
and growing demand for talent
offers the perfect incentive
for young athletes.
Right now, we're in the
middle of a historical event
for Cricket Finland
because we've never hosted
an international cricket
tournament before.
But I think from our perspective,
as a nontraditional country,
we've been looking at,
at the data that's come out
from our World Cup qualifier event.
There are quite significant
viewership figures
which have come through
purely from a Finnish-based viewership.
And I think looking at that
in terms of the way forward,
that's come about simply because
the game itself has become more attractive
for people to actually come and watch.
It's become something which
is more sold as a product,
has more things going on for the viewer
when they come to the ground.
We've tried to sort of mirror that here
with a very smaller version.
Obviously we haven't got a
hundred thousand seater stadium
as they've got at a
traditional cricket ground
in India or England.
But at the same time we have looked at it
to actually think about
how we can actually get
new people interested in the game
and have somebody at the
game that is referring
to what's actually happening
on the cricket field.
for somebody that's never
seen a game a cricket before.
For Finland,
a country whose own
national sport, Pesäpallo,
is also bat and ball-based, T20 offers
a potentially easy transition
for players and viewers.
You only have to look at the
average salaries of Pesäpallo
and IPL athletes to understand
the opportunity here.
In 2019, the highest salary
for a Pesäpallo player
was about $55,000.
That same year, the
IPL's top paid cricketer,
Virat Kohli's salary and winnings
came in at around $4 million.
That's not to mention the $21 million
he banked through endorsements.
The opportunities that are there for
players in nontraditional countries
to actually have access
to the the global stage,
whether that's IPL, whether
that's another franchise
somewhere else in the world,
or whether that's within the the
ICC'S Global Pathway events,
I think there's something which has
itself only developed in
the last five to 10 years.
Every other cricket board internationally
is trying this format because
they think it'll result in
them getting a lot of largesse
in terms of dollars that come in
and they can in turn improve
the local infrastructure
of the game in their respective countries,
which they probably can't do
given the current state of finances.
So it's a chicken and egg situation.
If they're able to successfully attract
and stage the first or second
season of the tournament
by attracting some world class players
and getting adequate consumers,
media companies will come
and follow those as well.
Now cricket is hoping to break into
the largest sports market
in the world: The US.
The US's Major League Cricket competition
is set to launch in 2023,
backed by investors such
as Bollywood superstar,
Shah Rukh Khan and Microsoft
Chairman Satya Nadella
The following year, in 2024,
Los Angeles will jointly
host the T20 World Cup
with the West Indies.
And there's also a bid by the ICC
to feature cricket for the
first time ever in the Olympics,
which will also be in LA in 2028.
With so much interest in
the sport and its expansion,
investors are picking
apart the business model
and exploring ways to
capitalize even further.
It has now gone to serious business where
large business owners across the globe
are seeing this as an
opportunity to own a franchise,
probably improve governance,
get more independent sportsmen
to come on the boards of these companies
and therefore attract the
best talent, get sponsorships,
and increase the scale and
size of what they can do
in their respective franchises.
Sport has become business
and sport is still run
and that is true beyond
cricket in other sports,
but particularly in cricket,
as if it's a cottage industry.
We haven't got off the field,
the sort of leaders and
administrators we need
to run a big industry like this.
An industry that appeals
to millions of people
and which can affect the
lives of millions of people
because for them it's
a form of entertainment that they value.